hello everyone
this is women's grandmaster sabina
feuscher
thank you for joining san luis chess
clubs
uh youtube live stream with me
um for this first lecture
uh which is called grandmaster's choice
i decided to talk about
um some mess-ups or missteps or
or just show some of
my terrible games in the u.s
championship
last year i hope you guys will enjoy it
i think it's always great
when someone is willing to share
um games that they mess up because
usually you are seeing
just the great stuff but there's always
so much to learn
from games that you mess up so i thought
it would be a nice topic without further
ado
let's get started i hope everything is
going
as planned and that i have
prepared everything as great as i could
all right okay
so
this was um
[Music]
this is a position from my game from the
first round
in the us championship last year which
is actually uh
which took place uh
online we played it on leeches
and the first round i played against
international master
and another favorite at the san luis
just club dorset de rakshani
she was playing in her second u.s
championship
and we reached this position
uh i i um
i thought i had a much better position
in this moment
um and so i
i mean why why is that because like
normally if you look at the position you
might not
really agree with what i'm saying but
basically
white has a slightly better pawn
structure if you're looking at white
spawn structure we only have
two islands of pawns black has three
has also these double pawns here on the
e file
the queen is kind of out of play but
something that's not so great maybe for
white is the fact that this knight is
not staying very well it's a little bit
passive
and it seems like black has a little bit
more space and with the file being
opened
it may seem like black is not doing so
badly but i did think
in the game that i have a small
advantage and i do have indeed
it is very important to take your time
and try to understand
you know what what are the weaknesses
that each side has
in order to be able to come up with your
next move
and the time control
i guess didn't permit me or it didn't
it didn't even cross my mind that there
could be some
tactical idea in this position all i
thought about was
well i have a badly placed knight
exactly as i started explaining to you
i was like okay i have a badly placed
knight in d2 i need to try to find a way
to improve it i need to get a little bit
more space
how do i do that right that's the
typical way that you
you look for things but if you get this
position and someone tells you
take your time think about the position
and
um there's a tactic
right if someone tells you that you will
immediately i'm telling you you will
immediately uh be able to
to figure out what to do here
unfortunately that was not the case for
me during the game
but now i'm telling you so we can spend
the time to evaluate the position a
little bit more and understand that this
pawn specifically in e6 and this one in
e4
because they are double they're also not
very well protected and because of that
we actually have
a way to win some material
here with white um
so the move that i should have played in
this position or
would have been possibly the best move
here
would have been knight takes e4 i could
take in c8 as well
first and then knight e4 and the point
is that after knight takes e4
we can take now so it really doesn't
matter the straight doesn't necessarily
matter if you do it first or not and
then we can go queen g4
by tagging those two pieces and
obviously you cannot go back knight f6
because we take and you're losing a lot
of material
so with black you probably have to go
knight g5
to give the piece back and not allow
white to take an extra pawn and maybe
even your rook
and then white would capture here white
has an extra pawn
an active queen the pawn structure is
still very good for white
big chances to win this right
yeah uh so the other possibility is of
course to trade as i said i don't think
i i considered this and i looked it up
with the computer as well and it didn't
seem like there was a big
difference between the two we captured
the pawn once again and then queen g4
with the same idea
getting one of these two pieces that
would have been something
much better for me to do and uh
when i looked look this game up like it
took me a little bit of time
after the championship to go over my
games and just
you know kind of remind myself
about the tough tournament that i had um
i felt really bad that i missed this
beautiful tactic and i thought okay this
will be a great example to show someone
at some point
i did show it to some of my students but
now i get to share it with the world and
it will always stay
here as um
you know tough
toughness for me now of course
you sometimes like it happens often it
could be
so many reasons why specific ideas
you're not seeing them
sometimes it's pattern recognition
sometimes
you just you simply don't have it
sometimes
you are so much focused on one what one
idea which is actually something that i
did myself i was so much
focused on trying to improve the
position of my night and
feeling that i'm a little bit restricted
that i completely forgot to think of
other things
that's why i believe it is very
important um
regardless of what your level is to take
time in positions where you feel you are
spending
too much focused on one idea to try to
take your time and
and uh just take a step back
and try to emphasize on
other possibilities maybe even take the
time to re-evaluate the position even if
you just played it right you think you
know everything about it
every new vision or every new
watch on a position can actually help
you come up with new ideas you never
know what you may miss
so try to avoid staying stuck on one
idea only
so here basically um instead of you know
focusing on that idea
i decided to improve my position and the
first thing that i thought was necessary
before i considered b4
uh and knight b3 ideas i thought i need
some air i need to create a luft
as the germans say so i went for h3
which typically is i would say a
very natural move prophylactic in a way
creating a loaf stopping any kind of
knife g4s in some situations
but this can also be a weakness and it
proved to be
something that helped my opponent a
little bit later in the game
she's made a mistake here she played
rook c7 which allows me to take
control over the c file which we will
see in a moment
instead of that i believe um she should
have tried to think what is her worst
place piece
in this position or what is the piece
that does not do so much anymore as he
was
doing previously and that was the queen
in a5
i believe you know for black it would
have been a nice idea to try to bring in
her queen
back uh you know on the king's side to
try to put in some pressure
on my king get to maybe defend the e6
pawn and uh just you know
still to be closer and then of course i
wouldn't have those
sacrifice ideas and also keeping the
looking c8 protected so in case of
capture queen takes
but she's made this mistake rook to c7
and i was very happy in this position
because i felt finally
i can improve the position in my of my
knight and take over the c
file the correct move here is knight b3
with tempo to the queen she i believe
she might my opponent might have missed
this move queen b6 only move and now
trades
and because i have my knight in b3 i'm
defending the c1 square so i can play
rook t1 and i took over the c file
so now if we take another moment to see
what has happened every time
there are trades on the board i think it
is very important
to um
to once once again take a step
back relax and
think about what you want to do
next or what has changed you you know
because you basically finished a part of
your plan
and you have to think about the second
part what will you do next
and um and in this case i think
for white realize that your knight is in
a slightly better position
you realize that you took over the c
file you realize you have the
opportunity to get the look
active on sixth rank maybe you can
double on the c file and get it even on
seventh
but you also have to think for the
opponent
and that is something we often forget to
do regardless of the level
and um as you can see i'm not just
trying to tell you what to do i'm
trying to acknowledge the fact that i
didn't do those things either
and and it's very important to remind
ourselves to do them
black has changed their position as well
with the trade that happened
and with the movement of the queen
coming on the f file
now black could have some opportunities
of attack
on the king side and that is not
something you should take
lightly of course you see that you have
the queening
when you're protecting the f2 pawn so
you're not even thinking that
something crazy could happen here but it
is certainly
something uh to be cautious about
because it means if you that you cannot
activate your queen your queen will have
to stay here
so anyways um in this position
i decided to go um
to i i've made a i've made a terrible
decision here
instead of following up with the idea
that i have in the first place which was
you know just basically activating my
rook
to c6 that was a very natural move that
i should have played here
it's a fork it's an active rook this
knight always has the opportunity to
retreat as well if needed
and the rook is the one that is over the
c file instead of doing that for some
reason i decided to go knight day 5
because i thought the knight would be
looking better in c6 remember it's not
about the looks
it's not about the looks of things even
if you are that kind of positional
player that you want everything to be
perfect and
happen according to something specific
no just try to think of what the
position may need but
require and if it's an open file and you
have
and you have just taken control over it
you want those open files for your rooks
you want your rooks to get
active so rook c6 should have been the
move for me to play instead i play
knight a5
now i'm not losing all of my advantage
by playing this move but it's certainly
a waste of time for me
and as soon as i play this move i
remember that i thought
about a very interesting idea that my
opponent could have
and she has almost immediately seen it
and played it too of course
so i remember when i told you that h3
was an
interesting um move for me an
interesting way to
um to get the luft and everything
and stop some knight g4 indeed but in
the same time
this has been created as a hook
a hook that allows black to find a way
to open up the g file in the same time
getting this g4 square for the knight so
she has played
this beautiful g5 idea
with you know the the follow up of
playing g4 trying to trade
they're getting the queen on the g file
knight to g4
and then putting pressure on f2 and
having mating threats in h2
so this has certainly come as a
how to say i was not very happy when i
saw this move
and um but i wasn't
it wasn't like an alarm sign for me
unfortunately it should have been
but it wasn't um
i thought okay g4 doesn't do anything
because i always get to take she will
take back
she will play queen g6 or queen g7 she
will take that pawn and then
nothing is going to happen really it's
just you know a little bit of an attack
but i'll get
to be active and you know everything
will be fine
little did i know
that that was going to cost me the game
i think considering you have to consider
the time control that you are playing as
well
i think that's also very important if
you play uh
short time controls maybe you have time
to swindle your opponent but if it's a
little bit of a longer time control
you don't really have the chance to do
that so
i think if you want to be cautious for a
potential attack you see that it could
be annoying
try to find ways to blockade things so
g3 probably should have been
a move for me to consider because the
point is that if you will
ever play g4 i can always play h4
keep the position closed there there's
no entrance for black
indeed i'm creating this hole for myself
and i'm leaving the f coupon backwards
but since the knight cannot reach to
attack f2 i mean it will take forever or
it will be impossible for it to get to
d3 i'm totally safe
so i can proceed with my attack and
ideas on the queen side with rook c6
and uh if she's considering something
like h5
i don't care so much because again i'm
doing the same thing
in h4 i can only stop that with g4
keeping once again the position closed
and there's no entrance for black's
pieces
no way to reach my king even if i'm
creating some weaknesses
of course this does not work in every
single position but here it would work
so i didn't feel scared just yet so i
went for rook c6
and now things are getting a little bit
scary because my phone played g4
of course that was the plan and
the first first moment where i'm
getting towards the worst position is
the fact that i decided to take
this is natural in a way to want to take
because you're thinking you don't really
want black to capture in h3 and actually
open up the file on your kink but
the point is that's not such a dangerous
threat
h4 would have been the alternative i
think
in a way to try to play g3 and kind of
get to a similar position as i showed
you previously
but i thought that she could give up the
pawn and this is a nice
optical idea a nice uh theme
to to be aware of that uh
when attacking you can give up material
to get squares for other pieces so you
give up pawns specifically
in order to mess up your opponent's pawn
structure or get
some outposts for some of your other
pieces if g3 was going to be played we
can just recapture
and then maybe they can play moves like
queen g6 knight h5
um there's the g4 square for the knight
as well
black will eventually get their pawn
back and my king will be a little bit
weak
so this was the reason why i didn't
quite want to play h4
something else i could have done though
was to take in d6
and then this position i did analyze it
a little bit with the engine
and it seemed like blank doesn't quite
have
a way to really take over my king i
should be pretty safe here because
next move i'll be able to play queen f1
try to bring the queen to g2 or g1 trade
it off
and black will not be able to mate me
and i've activated my rook
okay it should be pretty balanced
instead
as i mentioned in this position i played
h64
and of course you can only capture but
she had queen g6 that was all
part of the plan and this was the last
moment where i could try
to you know
uh you never go from a much better
position or maybe even like a
huge advantage you never go from that or
very rarely do you go from that to
completely losing
you need time for those things to happen
you have a couple of moves
to blunder and blunder and blunder or
make a mistake and another one and
and here i made the final one
i went for i was greedy i went for the
pawn
after which the position is completely
lost
instead of that i had to just maybe g5
or maybe
f4 i remember this was a move that i
considered but for some reason i was a
little bit scared of the ampersand
after pawn takes i thought black plays
h5 and my king will be completely naked
i'll have no chance
to to keep it safe in any way and
i don't know i just i just felt it it
would be really bad but you cannot just
go
necessarily just feeling you have to
spend the time and calculate
which unfortunately i did not do
in this case queen c2 probably would
have been a much better
uh i mean the move to consider
try to trade the queens so that the
opponent doesn't have
a chance to check me too
of course you would not have traded
queens maybe she's gonna play queen g5
but then i think i could just play a
four and just kind of force her to take
in g4 then go for queen g2
force the queen trade and this end game
i should not be
worse even if she has maybe a further
away past pawn i have my active rogue
the knight there maybe will finally make
sense
that i placed it there and things could
be
just fine
unfortunately what happened to me in
this game
i captured that pawn and it is clear
that now after knight g4 which
is something that that i missed i
remember uh i
saw that you would have the opportunity
to take here but i thought well you know
what it's not that bad i'm getting a lot
of pawns i can afford to sacrifice the
queen
for the rook and the night and as soon
as she played it
i was like wait a second i saw this
i knew this should not happen she
actually wants
moves like queen h5 and queen h2
and then it's a checkmate so like oh man
i realized what have i done what have
you done something i know and it's
it's it's just so simple
the toughest part is when you see
something
and forget about it or i don't know
something happens
and yeah anyways
so i played a few more moves here but
unfortunately
they weren't very very helpful she
checked me
i tried to run away on the other side
but after queen takes g2
f4 trying to trade my last chance to
trade queens
ampasant and now it is game over queen
f2
and i have no way to stop pawn from
promoting
unfortunately i went from a much better
position where i could have won upon
step by step into a much worse one what
was the lesson here
make sure you don't stay stuck on one
idea you see something that needs
improvement
good consider that idea but don't forget
there could be others
in a position the game of chess is so
amazingly beautiful
and you can be so creative there's
almost never just one
move you always have a multitude of
moves and have ideas you just need to be
willing to search for them don't forget
to search for as many of them
as possible the next position i i don't
know i mean
this was the order more or less in which
i played these games so
i'm not trying i'm not trying to uh
to pick someone i i didn't try to pick
someone in particular or such
but my next position that i want to ch
to choose uh was uh
an end game that i played against
another favorite from the sandler's
chess club
who is making great streams
for the club um talia cervantes
she's uh i'm i'm looking forward to see
uh everything she can she can achieve in
chess
she definitely has it and she's always
giving her
all when she she plays you can clearly
see that
uh in this game that we played i had a
much better position
in the opening and then step by step i
kind of messed it up
and uh got into time trouble i mean it
was a rapid so
okay we got both loan time and
eventually
reached this end game i had the white
pieces
and i thought in this endgame i had some
chances
um and um here she played bishop b6 the
bishop is attacked of course i'm trying
to get my phone back
here and i have the chance to take it
back and she has
to choose where to move her bishop she
chose the b6 square but maybe e5 could
have been slightly better with
with the idea that after capture going
back like
you know the this the square is control
i mean
okay i i would pick this pawn but i
think
this end game possibly trading
i think despite the fact that i have an
extra pawn and bish it's
bishops of the same color i think it is
very difficult for white to improve if
black just brings the king
you know in the center it it is very
hard to imagine that white can actually
improve
uh the position instead of that she
played bishop b6
and as i said it was a rapid
tournament so obviously neither of us
had much time
left here this is move 40
but if you have the time which i had
after playing the game
uh you realize what an interesting
position it is at least
i do believe so
um and white has a few options that have
to be considered
now what i can say is that i know a lot
of coaches
when they teach uh kids of you know or
adults of different levels they talk
about the importance
of um forcing moves
and when you see a position where there
are potential
you know moves that are forcing you
should consider them
and those kind of moves are checks
captures
or you know moves that creates a very
big thread like made forks
you know tactical ideas and
um those are the most
you know you should consider but also
you are told that you should try to have
candidate moves
although maybe not everyone agrees with
that kotov
used to have this book that that i
studied when i was a kid and
i was talking about the different you
know like
candidate moves you should consider like
a tree and you would write down
all of them and i remember i worked
through that but many grandmasters i
talked to these days
are telling me that they don't really
quite believe that is the
the way chess should be approached
these days i can't tell you exactly
but what i can tell you is that you have
to try to to do
to analyze positions the way you feel
um it helps you the most
um and so if you if you feel like
working with candidate moves helps you
make the best decision that's how you
should do it if you feel that you should
always look for forcing moves
you should consider doing that if you
feel that stopping for a second and
evaluating the position
first and looking for the weaknesses of
each side or
your badly placed pieces helps you
you can do that there are many ways you
can try to improve in chess
now in this position for white we have
two moves that make a lot of sense
and both of them happen to be captures
one of them is with check obviously
capturing in
in f7 and the other one is capturing
this bishop in b6
if you do have the time
you most likely will make the right
decision if you don't have the time
like i didn't have the time you'll make
the wrong one or maybe simply
i just made the wrong one and everyone
else would have made the right one
i don't know the point is that in this
position it is very important
to understand which pawns you want to
capture
okay which pawns you want to capture
because clearly you have the opportunity
to take two
but which ones is it going to be and in
which order
bishop takes b6 would have been the
correct way
to go about this position because now
we we trade a bishop so we go in a rook
end game
we are creating a new weakness for black
otherwise black
has that majority over there can always
play a5
and create a pass pawn and give
themselves a counter play
so you first do that and then obviously
you should take this pawn with check
the king has to go to g6 and here the
natural move
to play is rook f6 right so temporary
the material is equal
but now after rook f6 white is going to
win one of those two pawns
and then the other one will fall as well
so white will stay with a lot of extra
material
king g7 has to be played it is better
for black
in my opinion not to give up um
these pawns because these will be two
versus three and then
um there won't be the opportunity for
white
to to win on this side of the board but
the problem is after rook takes b6
you cannot defend this pawn and you
don't really have any kick or anything
to try to get the beep pawn
so once white wins that as well it's
going to be game over
if you try instead of that to go play a
move like rook here
it's still not helping because white
takes this pawn
and then takes this one and even if you
get those
two versus these three these
these are much these are much stronger
and white has the opportunity
to bring in the king to support the past
pawns
which he has i mean technically there's
just the f1 but there will be two once
h4 g5 is being played black's king will
stay on a mate
so white will be able
to win this end game it's pretty
standard pretty straightforward i was
saying
instead of that for some reason i took
this pawn
first and the problem now is that once
the king moves the rook is attacked you
don't have the opportunity to play rook
f6 anymore
black will have the the chance to trade
the bishops
and then you're not winning anymore
i played rook b7 with a similar idea
and now my opponent played rook b2 i
think
this is a moment she messed up a little
bit you could have taken my bishop
because the point is that now
um even if i win a pawn
right even if i win this one the king
can
approach and i didn't quite see a wave
like simple way for white to
to really win here uh because eventually
if these two pawns get treated
it will be it will be a draw three
versus two
if they don't get traded you don't
really have an improvement
so i think she should have traded the
bishops and go for the end game instead
she played rook b2
and gave me the opportunity to get into
a similar
um into a similar position as
previously shown so i took in b6 took
rook takes b6 rooks rook takes g6 king
h7
and here is
another position where you should try to
stay a little bit and think of what to
do next
you have natural moves and you also have
moves that
um may not be so natural but you have to
take them into consideration
so what do we notice here white has
these three pawns versus one
but their rook is attacked so once you
move it you have to think what black's
move will be and it is clear that rook
b2 will be the move to cut off
white's king not let it improve uh
go up to support the pawns and if that
happens it will be
very very difficult for white to
actually have a chance to win
because in end games it is very very
very important to bring our king towards
the center so that we can support
our past pawns and stop our opponents uh
past pawns
and here i can't do either one of those
two things
so i played rook b6 out of instinct
immediately
but once i stayed and i thought about
the position a little bit longer i
realized that that's
not the most important thing putting the
rook behind the opponent's past pawn is
not always the most important thing you
also have to
think about other characteristics in
this case
is the cutoff of the king which is going
to make it very difficult for white to
have chances to win
so instead of going rook to b6 i should
have gone in my opinion
i i think this would it would have been
the best try look to e6 the point is
that now the rook can come back to e2 if
if you play with b2
i can play rook to e2 thankfully in case
of a trade
the king is going to be in the box of
this b5 pawn
the box of the pawn on the side of the
border would be that and if you actually
want the whole box
it will involve that a file as well
and the point is that now if the rooks
get treated
yeah i am indeed winning if the rooks
don't get traded and my opponent gives
me a check
i can go you know maybe king f2 and
even if this pawn gets to be pushed
we actually can for example do this
try again trade so that i can go for the
pawn
if you check me my king goes forward and
my rook of course will stop the b-pawn i
always have the opportunity to bring the
rook back but what have i
succeeded in doing uncutting my king
which was my problem in that position
which is something also i didn't think
about
i just thought that i need to place my
rook behind the pawn because that is the
rule
but you don't always follow the rules
another thing that makes another
how to say uh something else that is
very important
for for all of us to think about you
know rules
in chess do not apply or
never apply a hundred percent you have
to be open to changes and that's what
makes chest so difficult
and so beautiful and so hard and
however you want to say all in the same
time
and you can't progress like that
immediately because you learn a rule you
think you know everything about it and
then
you find out that there are exceptions
and you have to be willing to accept it
and always take them into consideration
so this is a way in my opinion i could
have tried to win instead like i said
i play rook b6 and my opponent played
the right thing rook b2
to cut my king and not let me improve
and my last
hope here would have been to actually
say all right i made a mistake
let's try again and just go rookie six
and i love this idea because
i have another chance to try i mean it
may not be
exactly the same but because i'm a move
behind but i can still do it i can still
try to trade the rook
uncut myself and actually use my king
which is a very very important
piece in the endgame
and uh if i wouldn't have seen that
voltage obviously i didn't
you have to think about pawn pushes
right
you have to think will i put the f1 or
will i push the h1
if you have to choose between those two
take a moment and think about it
which one of those two pawns would you
push
and why it's very important because i
push the wrong one
now because i already have this arrow
here
um that is a hint that
that you should already have on the
board the point is that
for black in order to make a draw they
want to trade
the pawns right the more pawns that
trade the better it is for them
so if black plays in uh you know if if
you push
uh the wrong pawn rook h2 is an
opportunity for black to give up the b
pawn take the h pawn and as long as
their rook doesn't get trapped
there black is going to be able to make
a drawcast
there's just one pawn left to trade and
then we can have the philadelphia
no problem black skin is close enough to
get in front of the f
pawn so hopefully by now it is clear to
you that it is the
h pawn that i should have pushed so in
case the rook would come here i would
have the opportunity to push it forward
this pawn is very hard for me to protect
whereas this one is easier because my
king is close by if you go to b3 or
something i can
get uncut i can also protect the pawn
with my rook
if necessary i won't but that's the
thing to do
but that would have been the pawn if i
didn't see rookie six that would have
been a pawn
to try to push forward and then the the
idea is i mean
that for example something like this
could happen and then if you push b3
we could go f4 and you don't really have
a way to
to trade your b-pawn for either one of
these so this is basically the best
line that you can get but i think um
i think this
king king jr king h8 and then f5 i think
white has a big chance to win here
because um i i couldn't find a way for
black to
to take the pawns maybe they can try at
some point
once my pawns are on the same rank to
play something like rook d1 and when i
take just rook d5 or something
if you have the opportunity to do that
you can make a draw but otherwise no
so i played f4 instead it gave her the
opportunity
to to go rook before here
but so this this is a line that could
have happened
king g2 b4
king g3 rook c4 check
the king has to go back but this is
clearly winning for white because i can
just go king h4 king h5
there or take and and i would be winning
obviously rook b4 wouldn't be such a
good choice it seems natural right but
nah
but rook h2 rook h2 makes way more sense
as i was saying give that pawn take this
one and this
should be it wrong even if i get uncut
it's not sufficient for me to win the
game she did play b4 and gave me
one more chance in this position to
stop her from winning my h pawn i
probably could have played king g1
but make sure there's no rook h2
and then for example here check and then
we can go h4 to
try to get 85 in and uh and here once
again i think i have big chances to win
if you check me i go here
and i should be winning
and then of course we go g5 trades
push check push the pawns
so i made one more mistake playing f5
here
b3 last chance to go king g1
but i didn't do it i gave that check and
i played h4 and after rook h2
these pawns got traded off and the game
eventually
ended in a trap i'm not gonna go over
there's been
a lot of moves neither of us i think
both of us had forgotten how to press
to offer a draw that we had to press the
button twice to offer a draw we both
forgot about it
and unfortunately you know
we played much longer but
the game ended in a draw
all right so what did we learn from this
once again
it is very very important to
not to again like not to get stuck on
just one idea try to have the time
to to consider different options
make sure you find a way on how to take
your opponent's material the best way
possible
if you're getting into an end game that
most likely is a draw try to find the
way
the best way for you to still push for a
win
try to avoid letting your opponent cut
you off on the back rank
and especially if they have an
opportunity like she had
to give up a further away past pawn for
one of yours and then
simplifying the position more try to
avoid that as much as possible keep more
pawns on the board
to make it more difficult for everyone
to save the game
going on with the next position and
actually this one i'm going to
basically flip the board because
technically i did have
um
i did have black in this position
so um
this was uh this was very interesting i
do not remember exactly which round it
was
but um i can tell you that
i was a little bit
i thought i had a pretty decent position
throughout
if we stay here but just imagine it's a
new position and
you evaluate it
you realize it's pretty balanced we both
have the bishop pair
black's king is a little bit weaker due
to the fact that this bishop
has just captured h6 and that the rook
can come to g3 and put pressure which is
you know pretty obvious that it's going
to happen
but um you know we both have the bishop
there
and white is also struggling or has a
weakness
on back rank
and so we're both not having such
a safe king if we think about it
um my opponent played in this position
rook to g3
i was playing by the way you guys can
see um
ashrita eshwaran very strong
chess player from
i think she lives in california
and in this position she played rook g3
rook f4 would have been the alternative
like
move that you can consider oh it's four
that would be a good move
in your mind you can think that but
really after queen d7
uh rookie eights comes in next these two
bishops are protected and there's no way
for white to
to bring in the queen to actually have
serious making threat the rook g3 is
definitely the best move
for her and this is position where
a position where uh you do need a little
bit of time you do need to figure out
what is it that you're going to do and
um
bishop h5 is an option
queen d7 is an option queen e6 is an
option
and then taking the bishop with another
option a lot of options here for black
you have to try to find the best one how
do you do it
well this is certainly a tricky position
i would say
but um
i believe certainly this is a position
where you need to try to avoid giving up
material
like why would you give up material if
it's not necessary right the bishop is
attacked you can protect it
i didn't do that i like queen d7
very much i think this move was
necessary
because i'm taking the queen away from
an open file that i actually want to use
for the rook
i'm keeping my both bishops perfected
um
queen e6 is also nice because i would
protect but also put pressure on the
bishop in h6
if she brings in the queen this was the
move that bothered me a little bit
because now she's attacking the bishop
and i thought oh no i'm going to lose a
piece
but actually as i said i forgot to
consider the fact that my opponent was
staying on a back rank mate so i could
play no queen e6 i'm threatening the
[ __ ] up and i'm also threatening the
back rank mate
and she kind of has to play king f1 this
is basically the only move for white
if she plays for example rook takes g4
there's mate right i mean this is pretty
beginner
wise thing but you know i had to show it
um so she cannot do that so she kind of
has to play king f1
here and
i think i can take and then if she takes
i take back if she takes i go back
and then we have equal material opposite
color bishops
black shouldn't have any problems
drawing this
for some reason i don't know why i
decided to take the bishop instead
rook takes g4 check bishop my only move
is going back
and queen takes h6
a mistake a lot of people make is that
you want to
complicate the position a little bit
for a reason or another you want to
complicate it
and you think that by
sacrificing material you complicate the
position
unfortunately not all of us are
like fisher or petrogen
or magnus although we wish to be
playing as great we are not and so
often we complicate the positions in the
wrong
fashion you don't need to give up
material
always to complicate the position and
sometimes material is material
i mean you know
i know
in some situations we give it for for
right reason but
in this case particularly for me was not
the right reason it was not
necessary i haven't really improved any
of my pieces i lost the pawn
and now i have to find a way to
to keep the position i don't know to
defend
whereas with the other move you saw
there wasn't there wasn't a big deal
so i tried i thought okay i have
opposite color bishops i shouldn't be so
worried about what may happen
so i gave this check and then i played
queen to e5 the point being i want to
of course i need to defend the mate but
also that pawn is kind of hanging so i
can try to go for that
she played h3 and now i played rook d8
trying to bring in i have some activity
okay
if you are trying to equalize in a
position or you're trying to make a
drawing you realize you made a mistake
you have material disadvantage
try to think for easier easier ways
to to save the position what have i done
here obviously my rook is being attacked
right so what should you think about in
this position
you have a pawn down what kind what
types of end games
are going to be potentially helping
black to make a draw
that is the approach you should have in
this position right
what did i do definitely not that
um but if you're thinking about that
you're thinking which piece you might
want to trade and you see you have
opposite color push ups
so you can think in an opposite color
bishops and games
end game you have the opportunity to
draw
right so then you should tell yourself
okay
i should trade rooks i should trade
queens the simplest way
rook d4 right it seems pretty
straightforward
there doesn't seem to be a way for white
to avoid this trade
if the rooks get traded black should
have no problem
making a draw in this position if you're
not trading the queens
then this pawn is going to be hanging if
you trade the queens bishop takes back
and there's no improvement
there there's not going to be an
improvement for right
but instead of doing that i thought i
should keep the look on the board
wrong decision because the more pieces
there are on the board
the harder it is for you to to hold on
to the position too much
you have a lot of pieces they can put up
an attack as well
and let's not forget black's king is
pretty weak
she played bishop d3
which maybe wasn't the best she probably
should have played a move like b3 to
avoid allowing me to capture my pawn
back
and once again wrong decision i panicked
about a very simple check
make sure you consider your opponent's
threats they're real threats
don't fall for ghosts
free pawn i should have taken it i
didn't quite see a way
for white to get much after i would have
recaptured my pawn but instead i play
king f8
and now i fell for another tactic i i
missed
this opportunity that after this check
she can play f4
and now she forces the queens to be
traded
but not too bad either i basically
am going slowly towards an end game that
is beneficial to me if i get to trade
rooks as well
i am going to draw the this the same
game
so i play bishop f6 and i try to create
my counterplay this part of the game
i think i played pretty okay i've
created my counter play here
a little bit i'm trying to get these
pawns pushed forward to trade a little
bit
and then with my king and bishop i'm
trying to stop those pawns that was my
idea
and i've managed to do it really well
for quite some time
let's see f6 and then i played b5
and i played c5 and i'm wanting to play
c4
and then should play g5 probably
shouldn't rush to push the pawns too
soon
especially if there's a way for
for me to to stop everything but
unfortunately i didn't quite feed
g6 you put a pawn on white thinking that
now
she's gonna play a five bring her rook
like this
and then with that g pawn she's going to
be able to win the game
i played c4 which is a very natural way
as i said i want to trade
material and now she's bringing in her
rook
this is a moment where you have to
understand exactly
what is white's threat how serious it is
and what you should do next
so obviously when white plays rookie 3
they are not protecting the f-pac f4
pawn anymore
but they're threatening something very
serious check push the cheap one promote
it
nothing to do what shall black do in
this position
you have a couple of options one of them
is to take the pawn because it's free
supposedly the other one is to play king
f8 to avoid the rook getting there
and the other one is to play f5
out of these moves only one
kind of keeps black's chances
of making a draw alive and that move
is f5 it's a really nice idea because
you're opening up the bishops here not
letting the dru get active that's very
important you want to take the g6
pawn so their only way to stop that is
by capturing here
and now when you take an f4 you're
taking with tempo the bishop still
controls there's no rookie seven
and you need to move the bishop or play
to key five and after this
we have our options we can play c3 we
can play rook f2 try to date that pawn
oh
what a game this could have been it
could have been a completely different
result it could have been a completely
different game
but instead of playing that oh by the
way king of fade probably wouldn't work
either because
um
i can protect the pawn
and with the bishop in c2 is kind of
difficult to imagine that
there is there's progress if if black
plays here
bishop f5
and the king also can come and support
the past pawn
but i took here instead and i fell for a
very simple
tactical idea this is what happens also
when you don't have that much time by
the way
go here g7 check
and now obviously you can't play bishop
h7 but that's not necessary the bishop
can come on this other diagonal
there's no way to really stop it other
than sacrificing the rope but this is
not going to be sufficient
for me to actually save the game i have
an exchange down
white is winning more pawns it's just
game over i ended up playing a little
bit more because
i don't always like to resign
immediately but
that was that was it game over
well these were the games or the
positions
from the games that i played in u.s
women's championship last year
i felt for today
i wanted to show
that we all make mistakes and we have to
be willing to look them up
try to understand where we went wrong
and take them as learning experiences
to get to be better to improve
and try to avoid making those the same
mistakes again
you should never be feeling bad
about uh a position
that um
or a game that you played you should
never feel bad that you lost
i mean you should feel bad a little bit
i mean but
but uh but you should try to take it as
a way
to improve um
understand the mistakes and try to find
that kind of material
um in impositions from books or
or ask your coaches to help you
with uh with the types of positions that
you seem to mess up in your games
this was my choice for today's lecture
i really hope you guys enjoyed it i'm
going to be sharing
more things in the future uh but for now
this is it make sure you study your end
games
candidate moves uh evaluate
learn to evaluate the position and uh
be open to losing
uh with that said i'm going to finish
this video
and i hope i'm going to see you in the
next one where i'm going to show
uh my selection of this week's best
or my favorite games for this week
the ones that i was able to see and find
and i thought were cool
thank you so much everyone for watching
and
i hope to see you in the next video
bye for now